foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to our webinar today
titled from structure to function
combining the power of cryo-electron
microscopy and mass spectrometry for
deeper insights my name is Eddie Pryor
and I am a director here at Thermo
Fisher Scientific and will be your host
for today
our first speaker is Albert conanberg a
product manager at thermos Fisher
Scientific responsible for sample
preparation and our integrative
structural biology program
Albert will be providing a short
overview of integrated structural
biology and how using different combined
techniques can give a complete picture
of protein function
following's presentation our featured
speaker Dr Pascal Albanese will discuss
the characterization of a key enzyme in
the central carbon metabolism of
pyrococcus furious through an
integrative approach combining
structural mass spectrometry cryoem mass
photometry and molecular modeling with
molecular dynamic simulations
we'll conclude the webinar with a q a
session where the three of us will be
joined by Dr Rosa weiner from the
chromatography Mass spectometry division
here at Therma Fisher to answer any
questions you might have regarding the
integrated structural biology topics
covered in this webinar
thank you and with that I'll turn it
over to you Albert
so thanks Eddie for the introduction
so I wanted to start today with a little
bit of an historic view on the role of
structural biology and health and
disease so back in the 90s the idea was
that if we would be able to sequence a
whole genome especially a human genome
that we would hold the key to
understanding what was causing all these
diseases
however I said time and time again will
prove nature is much more complex than
that and what we anticipate
and for example even the same gene
expressed in two different tissue types
can already yield a completely different
isoform of the same protein
and so in the last two decades
proteomics became the way to go delving
deeper into the proteome trying to
identify and quantify as much proteins
as per as possible
and quite frankly you run into running
too quickly into another level of
complexity as we now are not only
dealing with varieties stemming from
genetic information but on top of that
also all kind of post-installational
modifications such as glycosylations or
phosphorylations
and although all this proteomic
information gives us great insights into
which proteins to Target for example
in order to study protein function and
to understand how a specific drug Works
um in order to treat the disease we need
to understand the protein structure
and where before x-ray crystallography
or NMR could only do relatively
well-behaved proteins of a limited size
even today cryo em can solve the
structures of much more clinically
relevant protein classes like tpcrs
with evergreater ease
and that brings us to this new era of
structural biology and a whole new role
for cryo VM
so in the last decade cryo VM has come a
great way both in terms of achievable
resolution that now ever gets closer to
that of X-ray crystallography but maybe
more important it makes great steps
forward in throughput and Automation and
that means that we can now also start to
think of not only elucidating previously
difficult to solve protein structures
but also running the microscope as an
essay almost
so here we show how in the course of
seven in the course of several days
different fragments uh to the Sask of
two Spike protein was screened as an
epitope mapping technique to understand
which ones could be neutralizing and
with epu multi-grade and now also with
smart epu the time spent on setting up
the microscope can be minimized we can
focus on on what we would like to see
and that's acquiring meaningful data
so in the next example here my
colleagues in collaboration with Basel
cable from icr London showed up with the
new glaciers 2 microscope after
optimization they were able to obtain 24
structures in a day's worth of
microscopy time for the cdk activating
kinase which is a private cancer Target
all with different small molecules bound
with only an hour of data per sample
they were able to obtain resolution
between three and a half and four and a
half angstrom which were good enough to
localize these small molecule binders
onto the protein structure
however
this is still solely protein structure
and thus provide the static view of a
specific state that the protein was in
and so to truly understand protein
function we need to understand not only
the structure but also its Dynamics
are there conformational changes so
bombining a drug for example or binding
another protein and that's the
preference of visiting certain
conformational States change if we if we
add a drug to it we know the protein is
rarely acts alone and so knowing which
proteins interact and where they bind
becomes critical in understanding how
they work
and then there's another layer of
complexity on top of that one that we
need to understand in the in the form of
protein forms small or large
modifications that are made to the
protein that can influence which
conformation they adopt or even if they
even prevent for example binding of a
specific protein
and the important here is that although
all these different types of information
are very different to know on their own
integrating them is really how you can
get an understanding of protein function
what they do under which conditions and
how to process uh and how of how these
processes are or can be influenced in
health and disease
so Mass spectrometry acquire VM are
particularly well suited to be combined
for to be combined
cryo VM can provide that high resolution
structure
but a difficult difficult Target
but because of the averaging During the
Reconstruction process it can be hard to
detect Dynamic post-translational
changes or even small conformational
changes
a good example are glycans for example
which are typically very flexible and
that means that in the cryo VM stock
structure we typically only see one or
two sugar molecules that we can identify
and that's not enough to really identify
the full glycans which are very high
type of biomolecule as they are very
branched
sorry
here glycoproteomics using orbitrap
muscle mass spectrometers can help you
identify the presence and preference of
these glycans without having to to
effort as we do in cryohea and on top
hydrogen on top of that hydrogen
deuterium exchange can provide an
insight into the structural Dynamics for
examples dose of an antigen binding a
specific region and the effect of a
specific lichen has on this this region
so when doing these complicated
workflows it is important you can build
on an end-to-end workflow
that it really integrates all the
different aspects
now whether it's for cryo VM or for any
of the different structural Mass
spectrometry experiments General Fisher
offers the full workflow including all
the relevant softwares to analyze the
data and to provide meaningful results
now what these results could be I'd like
to show you in the next two slides
so a great example of where cryoelectron
tomography and mass spectrometry came
together can be found in the work from
society and colleagues who use the
sarskov-2 virus particle derived from
patients to image the structure and
architecture of these in-text viruses
and this allowed them to quantify the
native structures of the spike protein
in pre and post Fusion conformations
and they then complemented this
information with the composition of the
ending glycans from Mass spectrometry
which is an ought to be processed very
similar to those of being obtained from
the recombinant spike protein used in
another of use in a lot of other
research also on which for example much
of the vaccine development was built so
really this provided an unprecedented
view of the intact virus but also
confirming actually that these vaccines
that were developed against the right
targets
to the next example this is really one
of my favorites and this is on the
nucleophore complex so this is a huge
protein complex of about 552 subunits
and more than 52 Mega dolphins
and the issue here is is that if you try
to purify this this protein outside of
the nucleus it really falls apart so the
only approach you can really take here
is cryoelectron tomography to start
Imaging these proteins unfortunately
given the adversity they give a
relatively low resolution of 28
angstroms but a team of of researchers
uh led by Michael route from from
Rockefeller was able to use an
integrated structural biology
approach using both cry of the
cross-linking mass spectrometry if some
native Mass spectrometry but also X-ray
crystallography and NMR structures in
combination with molecular Dynamics to
build this nine angstrom Precision model
and I think even if you don't know
anything about structural biology if you
compare those two structures you really
immediately appreciate the level of
detail but it doesn't really stop there
because if in green you see all this
very flexible regions which is sort of
deceive
um that determines what goes in and out
of the nucleus
from the cytoplasm and this model
actually gives them also a framework to
start actually looking into the
functioning of this nuclear bore
um at these nine angstrom Precision
model
so all in all integrative structural
biology provides us with a unique
ability to characterize protein
structure and function and the more
types of information we can combine
the more com the more complete the
picture of the protein that we want to
study we get both from a structural
dynamical but also a functional aspect
and if you'd like to learn more about
this apart from this webinar we just
have a new ebook available recently that
shows really how A lot of our customers
are using this approach to study protein
structure and function
hello good evening everyone or afternoon
or morning wherever you are connecting
to this webinar my name is uh Pascal
Albanese and I'm talking today about a
little bit of a weird topic but the the
the context is integration of different
structural techniques in particular I
will talk about an enzyme with tribes at
very high temperature and how
this is possible
so as integrative as an integrative
approach so this is more or less what I
will I will show you today I will of
course not go into detail of every
technique but mostly focus on why this
particular one was useful uh to answer
the particular biological question we
had but in principle this is based on on
a very uh basic features of of things
which is shape and mass and the shape we
can see structures of proteins with
cryum now with increasing details but we
can also model and predict how they
Folds
and and the mass is another feature a
particular feature of proteins which is
quite important if we want to look into
the details of it like first
translational modifications but also
when we have very flexible structures or
uh details that are hidden to cry M and
x-ray crystallography then we can
combine these data with for example
native Ms or mass photometry or chemical
cross-linking to get the bigger picture
and then we combine this with molecular
Evolutions to understand where these
proteins come from and how they work so
their functional Dynamics
and of course the bigger question is how
this
proteins they are built with the same
amino acids right but they try in very
different ecological niche
[Music]
and and now for example these organisms
they Thrive at nearly 100 degrees
Celsius I don't know how it translates
to Fahrenheit but it's boiling waitress
it's like the water you use to cook your
pasta into
and in particular is a branch of living
things that we always kind of forget
which are our key is but they are
actually our closest relative as
eukaryotes because
they are this organisms that
engulfed some bacteria to help them uh
with their metabolic rates with their
respiration and this is what became
later on our mitochondria but overall an
archaea is just an uh
eukaryotes or just archaea with some
bacteria insides
and and these particular ones they
adapted to very
um extreme conditions so they it's again
100 degrees Celsius so boiling water
very high soil concentration and they
are anaerobic uh this particular one is
called pyrococcus sporiosis
and what we do is try to fractionate
this proteome and maintain this
complexes intact because we want to
understand how similar enzymes they can
work at these extreme conditions and
what we we dig into these protons using
proteomics techniques so mass
spectrometry and the first striking
thing is that we see a lot of these
slicings with different oscillations so
oscillation is some ptms that modified
the side chains of Lysine
adding a different
branchings and what we see is many of
them so you usually it was like opening
a Pandora box because sometimes you
focus on a specific one on a specific
side but in this case the powerful of
this technique is that we can screen
many of them and we can look at all
these positions
and then we can also look where they are
so we can fractionate the native proton
and try to isolate different complexes
and what we notice is that specifically
it is a circulation on the lies it was
on high molecular weight complexes like
the usual subject you have
ribosomes RNA polymerase crispr casts
complexes
and quantitatively speaking we were
interested in In This Very abundant
protein which makes a really nice Spence
on the gels and this is something you
think okay wow this is a perfect uh
sample
it was a phosphonal uh pyruvate to
synthase I will come back to you later
on how this works but it was unexpected
how abundant was these metabolic enzymes
so it must be something a bit different
from the rest
uh
we tried to study this in the lab where
I am like I was
in the hack lab we have all sort of mass
spectrometers uh the thing we can you
can spray this protein natively and try
to guess its intact mass in this case we
had to squeeze a lot of transient and we
can get more or less the mass but if you
denature and reduce the protein to its
single subunits
uh you can see that basically it's it's
very heterogeneous so how we can deal
with this heterogeneity one of the
approach we can also we started to
explore more recently is uh Mass
photometry so
how this Mass photometry work it's it's
like in solution uh
scattering so you have single molecule
countings and you can get a distribution
of of masses
and with with every single molecule
being counted so as you can see here on
the right the distribution of this
complex even though it looks very very
uh pure on a gel it's very broad so it
means as we saw from the mass
spectrometry point of view it it
contains many different
the
many different uh
version of these proteins with different
ptms and we will see what we can see is
if we get a crying structure of these
complex
you we can get still to a decent
resolution so what you see here is that
we can solve the 24 meric structure of
this complex which is weight over two
Mega Dalton but this is not the complete
structure
from this structure with Gods we can
still answer
different biological questions so this
complex combines uh different features
so what you can see highlighted here
it's this dimeric interfaces between two
of these subunits
and this uh
catalytic course
are actually very conserved so if you
look at structure from
plants or bacteria
the
um
they are almost identical so they
overlay mostly precisely with the one we
got from archaea from this
hyperthermophilic Arc here and even in
the catalytic core if you look at the
side chains they are almost identical so
the question is how this enzyme can
actually survive
at these extreme conditions while if you
take plants or a
normal bacteria this protein and enzyme
will not work in the same conditions and
this has to do with its overall
States like it doesn't assemble as a
dimer it assemble is a 20 former and the
20 firmer is made of six tetrameric
modules like this which are actually
stabilized by Iron uh
atom in between so you have these four
uh c-terminal helices with an iron
sitting in there coordinated by four
methylenes and this iron we could also
detect by another Mass spectrometer
technique which is inductively coupled
plasma
and these tetramers it seems like it's
really an archaic feature because it was
shown also in the late 90s in staphylo
thermos which is an order archaea
where the same
um
kind of of sequence containing this
methionine it is there and also the
folding of the floating even though this
is r2d projections uh the looks to
assemble quite the same as in pyrococcus
so this methionine is conserved in
hyperthermophilic branches of archaea
and in some bacteria so we thought okay
maybe this is what makes this this
protein so sturdy and so resistant to
temperature and pressure
but what is this enzyme doing so it's
part of what is called the PPO node so
it's phosphenol pyruvate pyruvate and
oxaloacetate these three metabolites are
shared by all living things so this
enzyme or a different version of this
enzyme is present in all branches of of
evolution of life so
that's quite striking and how this
enzyme work is you have two catalytic
sites one is called the nucleotide
binding domain and the other one is the
pet binding domain and what we see with
the cryo yen is just this spec binding
domain so we only have this stable core
so we could actually only solve less
than roughly one third of the total
protein
and then you have an additional domain
which is called the CD domain so this
transfer domain that binds the
phosphates
and transfer it between these two
catalytic cores so you have to imagine
that this protein has to do so in
boiling water so you have these long
loops and this transfer domain that
needs to shuttle a phosphate group
between either ATP or amp and pack for
pyruvate and it has to do this in both
directions so how this can be actually
coordinated somehow or is it coordinated
so to prove this we can again leverage
activity assays and mass photometry so
what I try to test is increasing the
temperature and in a reducing condition
trying to see what's the turning point
of the enzyme so when it starts to
disassemble and not be functional
anymore
so as you can see on these plots I just
I put it really in summarizing so we we
put increasing concentration of reducing
religion which is d sub
at different temperatures and what you
can see is that at some points uh the 20
former is completely gone uh at any of
this temperature and what is popping out
is that we have a 10 millimolar t-cip as
a turning point we still can see a half
of the catalytic activity so we can
still see that the enzyme is active even
though we don't have the full 20 former
and we see these tetramers popping out
so most of the population is in this
oligomerization state we don't have the
dimer we don't have the 24 we have these
tetramers and we can measure these
activities so the tetramers is actually
the
catalytic unit the minimal units to
perform the catalysis
but where is the rest of the protein
because we are still missing most of it
so
how can we get there
we looked into uh different
classifications of this
3D
images
and we focused on on a single monomers
and we could see that we have variable
position of of this transfer domain the
CD domain
and now we got to include the
cross-linking mass spectrometry because
we see the sequence we know that we have
a complete enzyme we know roughly that
we have the total mass and we have a
threat former so how can we get
everything into the model so we leverage
as I said press linking Mass the
geometry so we use reagents that are
forming covalent bonds between lies in
residues
and then we tryptic digest the samples
we do some enrichment because we use a
phosphonate handle uh in the chemical
Linker
and then by mass spectrometry we can
figure out which
license were in close proximity uh in
the starting sample
so with some modeling we can actually
predict nicely the structure of the the
NBD so the nucleotide binding domain
which is this n-terminal domain which is
completely
transparent and not detectable by cry um
and we use cross-linking restraints to
dock and to build the full model
or something that should look like
something let's say that we think it's
close to what is really in solution
and then with this model we had to test
because what happened here so if you if
you go back to if you remember my first
slides we saw that this this complex was
heavily modified and it was heavily
modified on lysine so and now we are
using a lysine uh reactive reagents
right so
what happened here is that
we have we identified some sites that
are highly acetylated and most of them
are found acetylated but only 14 of them
are with high occupancy which means that
roughly half to ten percent of it it's
actually acetylated in every state but
this is not always the case and where
however there's a situation coming from
what are their effects on the wall
structure
so to investigate this we we assembled
the full complex for what we think it's
the full complex based on our data or
the integration of those and we try to
run
more than accurate Dynamic simulation so
we had to course train this so it means
to simplify the atoms to something we
could actually simulate because we are
talking about millions of atoms and
over to Mega Dalton complex
and we test this at 90 degrees with and
without acetylations of course the full
model it's this is the starting one but
when you start to simulate after MD it
doesn't look it's a bit more ugly that
what you think it's your beautiful
starting model
but what was nice to see is that
actually the the simulation goes hand by
hand with the cryium density so where we
got the most mobile part of the complex
yielded to no structure the central
domain where the mobility is yeah let's
say between uh 10 15 angstroms from the
starting model then we had some low
resolution structures at around seven
angstroms
and the core which is the most stable
part there we get two 2.5 action
resolution
but what's the role of this acetylation
so the beauty of the simulation is that
we can build the model with and without
acetylated license so when you get the
lighting seams what you can see
is that all these arms they tends to
fall apart or they are not really well
coordinated here I extracted one of the
tetramers because we run many of those
but when you introduce these
acipulations on this specific highlight
spots you can actually appreciate
that they tends to form a dome-shaped
structure and they are way more uh
better coordinating between them
and it was quite striking at some point
to see that the central domain which is
important for pathologies we could
actually see it approaching the other
catalytic domain so it's sitting in the
position where it should go when he has
a phosphate to transfer and we also
introduced this phosphates as a PPM on a
specific and key residue in there so
it means it starts to mimic what should
be the actual catalytic mechanism of the
the enzyme
and everything starts to make sense
again because if you then look now I
plotted here what you can see is the
crosslings
on the simulated structure so you have
some of the crossings that
starts to make sense now after MD
simulation so
in our model we had all Overland
Crossings because we assume a Crossing
should be within 30 angstroms distance
which is like the size of the Linker
plus the side chains of the lighting
after MD simulation you can nicely see
that even if we isolate these complexes
many times by size exclusion or sucrose
gradients
they fall within range again so
this is quite important so mind your
model when you do this experience
but
what what is the source and and of these
acetylations because you can think okay
I mean we are used to think of uh post
translation modifications as something
that has to have a function on on the
protein right it's like okay we have an
enzyme that puts this acetylation there
or this phosphate there and then the
protein changes function hatching this
target but in this case I had to dig out
because this was clearly unspecific
because we saw all of the Legends with
acetylation so either or not and there
were some studies in mitochondria that
shows
that if you have license and systems
that are close enough
with high concentration of acetically
around 10 1 to 10 millimolar you can get
the transfer of this acetyl group from
the
acetically to the lysine
and then it was interesting because I
started to look in our structure where
the systems are and where these acetyl
license are
and then if you with I looked into also
other complexes in paracoccus that we
could see highly acetylene by Massive
parametry
and then you can actually see that the
systems are usually alone so they are
not forming diesel fight Bridge with
anything else and they are in between
this monomeric domains and if you look
at the distances that you can see that
they're actually pretty close it's not
10 to 12 as they calculated in
mitochondria but we are also talking
about organs that thrive at very extreme
conditions so the flexibility and
mobility of this protein is completely
different also the chemical reactivity
in there
so this is a possible mechanism but it
also drives to other uh thoughts so what
is the evolutionary background of this
so we
we have everything settled in eukaryotes
to to to control these ptns but in ppsa
and what we saw in all the uh acetylated
lighting sites that we saw we don't have
any uh sequence logo or motive that
could lead us to think that it's
something which which is uh mediated by
another enzymes or controls so it has to
be completely spontaneous and that's
quite striking because it means that
probably these ptms evolved by being in
the first primordial brought something
completely randomly occurring on protein
surface it's not something that that
proteins knew how to cope with so it was
just
that's why in the end we have these huge
amounts of this ppsa complex in there
because it's it's so important for the
metabolism so without it you don't have
any metabolic roots or Pathways so it's
key for making the the
organism alive to keep it alive
but it's it's getting randomly modified
but by these environment because it's
not compartmentalized
and as a small note in the end uh I
wanted to show that with these
experiments we can also integrate uh
different uh data again so what we saw
in these experiments is that we could
reproducibly co-purify another protein
which is called pck and if you look at
the the en data you can barely see some
classes where you have an additional
Dots here and there it's not really
resolution there it's it's documentric
amount but we could detect crosslinks
very reproducibly so we could see this
connected to the main complex so we can
use these crosslinks and co-evolutionary
links to dock this additional protein in
there and why this protein is important
because pck it's actually converting
oxaloacetate to pep so it's it's working
on the same substrates and products of
this ppsa so This suggests that ppsa can
have actually a Moon Lighting features
have as
other very abundant enzyme of the
metabolism in other organs
what about Alpha fold of course I didn't
talk about Alpha fold of course we tried
but it's it's missing some of the key
um
data underlying uh this complex right so
even if you try to predict the tetramer
this is what's coming out so
whether this will replace completely
structural biology in the future I think
that's not the case as we saw to to
solve the structure and to answer our
very specific questions about the
biology of this enzyme we needed plenty
of techniques and plenty of different
source of data
so I hope I could uh show you a bit uh
how we got there so how none of this
technique was was actually completely
satisfying or giving any groundbreaking
results but how just the combination of
those
could could start to unveil how these
ptms would make this enzyme alive and
functional and structurally sound so
of course this was a truly uh
integrative work so many people were
involved for our part it was only not
only Mass spectrometry but we did all
the biochemistry and the production of
the proteins uh collaborators in [ __ ]
and did all the functional essays
um and the turmo they they granted us
the access to to many beautiful
instruments that were instrumental to uh
everything that I presented today so I
just want to thank everyone involved and
all the people in in Utrecht and in the
ACT lab if you want you can look at the
reprint is there there are many more
details or you can contact me and thank
you for your attention